hi there hi Steve coffin here thank you
for the many comments that I received in
response to my previous video where I
asked you know what are the problems you
have in learning specific languages
today I'm gonna talk about the
subjunctive in French which was one of
the more common difficulties that people
expressed in their comments remember if
you like my videos on language learning
please subscribe so the subjunctive in
French you know I think was Harry Truman
who said it's not difficult to know what
the right thing to do is the difficulty
is doing it so I think with the
subjunctive the basic principle is not
that difficult
in other words anytime you have a
situation where there is doubt in other
words it's any situation of uncertainty
possibility even obligation in other
words it's not certain that something is
gonna happen that's where the
subjunctive comes into play so you know
I have to do something you focus your
fuss even must so Monica Seles what you
know it seems to me you're not pause but
I don't think that it is you know your
postbox s wah Joon Papa Grandpa's back
in Vienna you know anything that is
uncertain like that implies the
subjunctive simple rule now the fact is
that many people are very fluent in
French and don't use the subjunctive
correctly all of the time okay
and that includes French people so for
casual conversation I wouldn't worry too
much about it I mean I think as a as a
matter of personal pride certainly I'd
like to use the subjunctive correctly as
often as I can but I don't worry about
when I miss it and very often I'll watch
a video that I did in French and I'll
see that I there were in cases where I
should have used the subjunctive and I
didn't and that's the other thing about
mistakes in general it's not it's normal
that we sometimes get it right and
sometimes get it wrong it doesn't matter
you know what the issue is articles for
people speaking English who are native
speakers of a language that has no
articles sometimes they get the article
right and sometimes they get it wrong
not a big deal now it depends of course
what your goals are
you know if you're communicating
casually in conversation it's not so
crucial even if you're using and using
French on Twitter or you're doing
business via email I don't think people
are going to be worried about whether
you get the subjunctive right however if
you're living and working in France or
if you're in an academic environment and
you have to get it right then of course
it's a bigger deal but fortunately most
of the time if we're writing something
that's more formal we have access to
Google so we can Google you know evoker
does that take the subjunctive you just
put up you [ __ ] and you'll see what
exactly is the imperfect subjunctive or
whatever Google conjugate the verb venir
and you'll see what the the you know
subjunctive in that tense is so when
you're writing in a more formal
situation you have the ability to find
out you know what is correct usage when
you're speaking naturally if you have to
every time think about whether this is
the subjunctive or not the subjunctive
you'll be tongue-tied so I don't
recommend doing that now in so far as
how to get better at the subjunctive all
right you can read the rules it'll be to
two paragraphs and you'll understand the
basic principle but that doesn't mean
you're gonna get it right you're only
gonna get it right if you develop
certain habits and this is the same with
so many aspects of languages and I'm
going to get into these and in later
videos where I address some of the
comments that you made you have to
develop certain habits and the way you
develop the habit is to focus to start
noticing and and in a concentrated
fashion so for example and let me also
say that I'm not a teacher
so I'm not gonna teach you the
subjunctive but I'm gonna tell you what
I do I'm gonna use my experience and how
I deal with this
in French you have to start noticing it
so if you read and you see the
subjunctive or what you think is the
subjective underlying it when you hear
it try to notice it a little bit the
other thing of course I study on link so
I would recommend if you're using lane
can I do recommend that you use link
there's a number of things that you can
do link of course Li ng q that's the
website that I'm a co-founder of and
where I have done all of my language
learning for the last 10 years and so
one of the things that I can do is as
I'm reading first of course I can save
words and save them to my database for
review I can say you know you know you
focus your sachet focus your shot you
have to know I can save this such okay
if I save the sash as a word as a CH e
SE focus on I can tag that as the
subjunctive also by saving the word sash
which is the subjective then I
automatically end up with four five six
example phrases chunks of language that
the link system captures so I can review
those so I'm getting this concentrated
exposure to this subjunctive pattern at
least in the use of the word such and we
have text-to-speech for each of these
captured chunks of language so I can
listen to them and it's just driving so
you focus on focus to such so that's
starting to become a habit now I can
save if a you know even the some
bloopers so that no slop ah okay
swap I can save swap tag it again as the
subjunctive and I can do the same I can
also save the phrase Avoca to swap it
folks that's what and so I save these
phrases so and when I go to review my
words or phrases I can in the vocabulary
section say I only want to review
phrases only which are tagged
subjunctive so now I've got a whole
bunch of these that are concentrated
examples of the subjunctive in use so in
doing this and I've done this for
example
in in Russian for cases and stuff like
that you have to get that exact
concentrated exposure it's I often talk
in language learning about the big
picture which is listening and reading
to things of interest but you do have to
spend some time with the nuts and bolts
if you want to get better at them
because by spending time with the nuts
and bolts you get better at noticing
what's happening in the language and the
better you notice the language the more
likely you are to start reproducing the
language correctly now
you don't have to be a member of link or
you sling but that's just as an example
so if you don't not on link you're
reading a newspaper you're you you see
this adjunctive
underline it somehow make a note of it
start to fix that in your brain and
eventually the brain will get used to it
because in order to get the sajama
subjective correct on the fly while
you're speaking you have to have those
habits ingrained in you and then you
don't have to think about is this
objectless the subjunctive
what is the subjunctive third-person
past present future it'll just come out
naturally because you have been exposed
to those phrases so often so there you
have it that's my take on the
subjunctive in French I look forward to
your comments bye for now
[Music]